first ballot selection to the Canton
class of 2017 he's a good buddy
LaDainian Tomlinson how are you LT I'm
doing well rich excited about this
weekend and you got you've got it all
set up this it feels like it's a little
bit of a calm before the storm I've
caught you in a spot right now yeah it
does that's absolutely correct um you
know of course I got here to Canton
yesterday and now here I am Thursday
morning and and I'll tell you I wake up
this morning and I got a bit of a break
but I'm spending it with my family so
we're gonna go have a nice breakfast and
just kind of hang out and dinner right
around three o'clock is when the badness
will start so so it's kind of the quad
before the storm
yeah heading in the stadium for the game
tonight Arizona and Dallas and then the
jacket dinner Friday and then so on and
so forth all the way up to the speeches
and I had Kurt Warner on earlier in the
week and he said that you and he and TD
have spoken a lot throughout this
process and that's no surprise but he
said that you were done with your speech
almost a couple weeks after being
announced as an enshrining is that true
that is true and you know it's um the
bulk of the speech was all weighted down
and then you kind of go through it you
make minor changes because you know the
Hall of Fame really clamps down on your
about the amount of time that you're
going to spend on your speech and so of
course I came in my initial speech was
right around 20 to 25 minutes and they
say oh well that's way too long then I
cut it down and so spent the rest of the
time kind of find the ways to cut it
down and take things out and just keep
the stuff that I really want to talk
about and things that are really
important me but yeah I will confess
which I I started working on the speech
before I was announced okay oh oh you
know you can't help okay you know what
it's understandable
you know because it was it was a
no-brainer
like I said that you were going to get
in but that said you know I know that
they might get them they might you know
come after me and I might get in trouble
for saying this
there's no red line number you know
Favre spoke for damn near 40 minutes
last year there's no trap door that
opens no large cane with a hook that's
going to take you off the stage LT you
know yeah I know you know and you kind
of you think about that and in here's a
day you know you have a little push back
also you don't say god I got really one
you know talk about these people and say
these things so you compromise a little
bit and I think we're at a good place
where it'll satisfy the whole of thing
um all the fame you know committee and
all the guys here but also a little
satisfy myself
and I'll get to say what I need to say
so what would the kid from rosebud Texas
growing up little kid think about being
in the Pro Football Hall of Fame if he
knew Lt Wow
I think just uh you know from my
perspective to always think about my
family heritage and my family game and
all that kind of stuff and this is you
know to be immortalized in this facet
you know I'm the one to be able to to
kind of take my family name to this
point it's truly humbling it really is
it's a it's a tremendous honor for all
of us my entire family and so I'm so
proud to you know to represent us when
did you realize you had a special gift
um you know honestly I kind of you know
it's weird because you go through like
when I when I look back on my life and
my journey you know I knew that I was a
pretty good athlete because I was you
know I was faster than most of my peers
so I can see it and the first time I
touched the ball in popcorn I ran I ran
a touchdown and I was one of those kids
that always kind of stood out play
quarterback but really ran around
because I was a really good athlete and
and so you you have those those
the times where you say you know what
like I think I think I'm pretty good but
then there are other times where you
feel like the talent level catches up
with your talent and so certainly I
think right around high school that
happened to me and where I had to play
fullback for two years my sophomore
junior year and really didn't get a
chance to carry the ball and play
tailback them to my scene here and so I
went through a period where I didn't
know I just didn't know if I was good
enough and then obviously college is
when I kind of rose again to the
national ranks of doing breaking records
and all those kinds of things so to
answer your question really which it
wasn't until my junior year in college
that I said you know what I'm good
enough and then you know you're you're a
team player even though there's tons of
eyes and your first and last name
combined LT and part of it you know is
evidenced in the fact that you've chosen
Lorenzo Neil as your presenter the the
guy who was right in front of you at the
neck roll and just barreling down hill
to blow open any extra holes that your
offensive line did not in your
record-setting seasons in San Diego why
did you choose lo Neil and by the way
thank you for putting him on a national
stage once again the folks are going to
be very entertained by him over the next
few today yes of course you know Lorenzo
lives so you know he's never short of
words and entertainment so um but no I
just feel like you know Lorenzo is a God
that is so selfless you know book of a
player he sacrifices for the team and
think about his position is to clear the
way for other guys to shine to get the
credit and and you know for most of his
career he did that to the best of
anybody in the National Football League
I think 7,000 yard rusher C Block four
but when I think about my career what he
did for me
he took my game to another level um you
know most of those record runs touchdown
record-breaking runs he was in front of
me and so I felt like in my biggest
moment going into the Hall of Fame is
only right that this guy lead me out
into the Hall of Fame
Levent LaDainian Tomlinson here on the
Rich Eisen show a few more minutes with
him and then while we're on the subject
of former players here LT much made this
week about Philip Rivers whether he was
going to be there Antonio Gates or that
he was going to be there and whether the
Chargers told him not to be there can
you walk me through the process with you
and these two players Anthony Lynn the
franchise and and set everything
straight that she can know yeah well I
think early on I knew that a Phillip
I've reached out to me a while are going
to hey man you know I really want to
come cook you know we're in camp and I'm
going to do my basket man talk to the
coaches and talk to Dean and see if you
know if we can make it happen and and
then you know I knew that they had the
big scrimmage with with the Rams on
Saturday and so at that time you know
Philips the quarterback you know he's
the leader of that team and leader of
their franchise and it will be really
hard for him to miss something like that
as a quarterback first scrimmage but not
only that first appearance really in
that LA market at the stadium at the
stadium were they're good they're going
to be playing games and so at the end of
the day Phillip will not be able to make
it but Antonio Gates will Antonio is uh
he's got permission from Anthony Lynn
and I look I talked to Anthony body he
discussed it and and I think we all were
on the same page in terms of Antonio it
was something that he really wanted to
do but also you know where Antonio reels
in his career you know the guy has done
everything he's going to be in the Hall
of Fame one day and so the experience we
shared throughout my playing career we
had a special bond and he he was adamant
about being here and Anthony Lin didn't
try to stop and want one bit and so at
the end of the day Philip is going to be
a discriminant and Antonio Gates will
come here to the instrument so Philip in
and you're cool or he wanted to make it
and you just figured it was just too
difficult to do it I mean
absolutely no absolutely we're
absolutely cool Phillip not have a
really really good relationship you know
but but these circumstances especially
when you're the quarterback of a
franchise yeah you know you have to be
there and then and then about if the
franchise just to talk a little bit of
football over here
it's remarkable Mike Williams not on the
field and then Forrest lamp goes down
with an ACL yesterday yeah is there
something in in the water in the
facility regardless of where it is with
the Chargers LT it's unknowable no you
know unbelievable uh you know and I
don't understand how that continues to
happen I'll tell you it's just a bad
stretch right now and seem to be going
through but I'll tell you you know I am
encouraged about Mike Williams I don't
you know I don't anticipate him being
gone for the season I think we will get
him at some point get him back but I
said that of course and I mean the kid
was making strides and he was really
starting to show some promise you know
and so now he obviously he I think he's
going to be out for the season almost
positive with a CF ACL tear but you know
he I think he has a bright future Don
and that's the only thing that we can
look to at this point all right well LT
I know that you take it some time out
the rare moment you're going to have
with your family so I appreciate you
calling in I'd like to make one
suggestion Kris Brockman and I workshop
it and yesterday's show about how you
can work the teardrop into your Saturday
moment on the stage okay all right I'm
assuming you you will but maybe you work
maybe you put this wrinkle in or if you
haven't I think that's what you should
do when you and lo Neill stand next to
your bust with the I guess a piece of
burlap or a very nice piece of Velveteen
that they have over your bust you reach
over and you remove you reveal your bust
by reaching over and flipping your hand
up tear dropping
the covering off your bus over that is
pretty unless you know what that's a
great idea rich I haven't thought about
this I was thinking about perhaps taking
the mic and dropping the mind you know
to drop in the mind and I said what I
gave a prophet came up with you're
dropping the mic I could like you that's
a good one but you could just put you
know put one hand behind your head and
then reach over and tear drop the
covering off and then loan you like
Yanks it off at the same time I like
that we're gonna see what what happens
all right I got some ideas now oh yeah
you know what hand people I just want to
be a factor LT I just congratulations a
long time coming
expected but nonetheless soak it in as
much as you can enjoy it thank you so
much rich always declares in my friend
likewise right back at you look forward
to celebrating with you that's LaDainian
Tomlinson calling in from Canton Ohio a
couple days before is enshrinement here
on the Richard show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show up follow
all the information you see right here
on the Rich Eisen show